[Música]
y es directo ahora vamos hasta México
para hablar con nuestro corresponsal
Mario carbonell sobre la situación de
seguridad en ese país que vivió un nuevo
episodio violento y una de las masacres
más mortíferas en lo que va del año a 20
subió el número de Muertos tras un doble
ataque armado en el municipio de San
Miguel totó la totolapan en el Estado de
Guerrero entre las víctimas se encuentra
el alcalde Conrado Mendoza y varios
funcionarios más Mario muy buenas noches
cuéntanos Qué reportes se tienen de la
situación que se vive allí un día
después de lo ocurrido
Así es pues actualmente se vive un
ambiente de desolación de acuerdo con
distintos reportes locales las calles
lucen solitarias Un día después de este
artero ataque
al señalar que se llevaba a cabo la
Feria la feria patronal de San Miguel
Arcángel y pues había un ambiente
festivo previo a este ataque que
contrasta mucho con el ambiente que
ahora se percibe en esa localidad de la
Tierra Caliente de Guerrero Incluso se
suspendió actividades como la vacunación
a los niños contra el 19 entre otras
actividades públicas que se suspendieron
desde luego también la feria quedó
suspendida y se llevan a cabo en medio
de un fuerte dispositivo de seguridad
los sepelios de las personas fallecidas
excepto el del alcalde Conrado Mendoza y
su padre pues sus cuerpos aún
permanecían en el servicio médico
forense en la ciudad de Iguala para la
necropsia de ley
este el ambiente que se vive actualmente
Mario vimos que el presidente amlo
atribuyó a la masacre a la
descomposición derivada del
neoliberalismo Según dijo pero qué ha
dicho la gobernadora de Guerrero y Qué
acciones y medidas está llevando a cabo
las autoridades tras este multi
homicidio
sí la gobernadora Evelyn Salgado bueno
retomó Incluso el discurso del
presidente en el sentido de que es una
situación heredada de gobiernos
anteriores donde se produjo esta
descomposición sin embargo pues se llamó
a la población estar tranquila dijo que
ya hay una fuerte despliegue de
seguridad
una centena más de una centena de
elementos de distintas corporaciones de
seguridad entre los que están la Marina
la guardia nacional el ejército y
también policías estatales para
resguardar a la población a cuidar a los
familiares también durante el sepelio de
sus seres queridos Y también se está
llevando a cabo esta instalación de las
llamadas bases de operación mixta en ese
sentido la gobernadora hizo un llamado a
la población a que permitan la
instalación de estos retenes de estas
rondines de seguridad pues ha habido
ocasiones en los que los pobladores
rechazan esta presencia militar hizo un
llamado también a la fiscal Santa luz
valdovinos acelerar las investigaciones
y que se dé con los responsables de
estos hechos pues garantizó que no habrá
impunidad algo que bueno se dice en
reiteradas ocasiones cada que ocurre una
homicidio y más de esta magnitud